And Candida cause cancer.
Well, anything that can enter into your cell and interrupt affect the nucleus and interrupt the replication cycle can be a cause of cancer.
So yes, I guess it can.
Testing have we seen that maybe a few times, but if you the rare side, what herbs or IV treatment is good for Candida, how would burberry be good for cancer.
Thank you.
So I pulled up the product label or the Candison forte, which is the product that we use a lot with Candida.
It's a more than molecular product and just to show you what what is in there that has been shown through different studies that can be helpful for Candida.
Burberry is one thing on this list that can be very helpful for Candida, what else is burberry and good for.
Well, burberry is really good to lower your glucose levels.
The ability who has cancer who's trying to keep a lower blood glucose level burberry is really good somebody that has elevated glucose levels due to, you know, prediabetes or diabetes type two diabetes using burberry can be really good.
What else is burberry good for burberry is the best killer for h pylori what's h pylori he look go back to pylori is the number one got infection that can cause that is 100% times.
It's all the all sort of intestinal ulcerations like stomach ulcers and doanda ulcers ulcers 100% of the time it's caused by h pylori over growth also about a fourth of the art disease and cord area disease issues are caused by helical vector pylori.
It's really with a chronic helical vector pylori infection is is important so that's why I've told you in the zoom calls over the years that I take burberry not every day, but I take it every month i'll take it for about a week just because I have a history in my family apart issues and burberry is something that's really good for that.
So anybody has a history of heart issues history of candida history of gut infections parasitic infections history of stomach ulcer and or you know burberry is a good cancer killer in once in a sense of that it can kill a cause of a cancer if it's parasitic or bacterial related.
And secondly it can help decrease glucose levels which is always good for a cancer patient so burberry doesn't really good for a lot of things it's one of my favorite supplements regularly if caprylic acid cinnamon and other things on this list are good for candida.